how's it going resumes P welcome back to
some more goat simulator I'm excited to
keep playing this what's this hitchhiker
go what does that do side play music
[Music]
let's take a shortcut with this guy I
love it oh gosh Wow we're still going
goat never lets go let's find my more
secret lies in this map then we'll walk
on me [ __ ] oh god what the hell like
calm down it's okay alright we got a bar
here [ __ ] is scared that's right you
better move it
I just redecorated but the [ __ ] oh god
sorry about that
you're welcome for the decorations
what's for the arrows
what just happened what just happened
dance I said I said dance that's right
you [ __ ] be dancing oh what a
wonderful statue such posture let's go
up here I want to try these at oh
there's a ladder Jess sweet my face is
too big there we go wonderful
that doesn't look weird at all all right
we're up here now let's look it now God
why did I do that
seriously yeah hey that's why if there's
something on top of it why is there
raining whales over there what the [ __ ]
what what the what what what are you
doing why I don't what this is [ __ ] okay
I can't lick them you're my new best
friend come here Willy what I don't get
it what am I supposed to do with you -
goat or not to go to that if the
question allow on my tongue is sticking
out my that's my whale can I go inside
him the real question is can he dance
[Music]
that might be a little of course you can
look yeah yeah you keep dancing
Whaley Willy god oh god that mom is
terrifying adventure Willy
this looks very nice don't mind me I'm
just taking my whale for a walk that's
right you better dance [ __ ] oh I see a
goat in there yeah
I unlocked classic goat all right let's
try that out
penguin goat yeah that's fantastic oh my
god this is the best
I'm such a [ __ ] clients a goat man ah
it's really fast look at that [ __ ] I'm
like a torpedo
oh god I'm slow I do I would like to
have some I'm so slow I wonder we can
swim faster some shed wow what a great
swimmer
fantastic penguin right there I mean
classic ode of course you swim so well
oh there's money here a lot of money
nice all right [ __ ] take my money and
we go oh and I'll pick my witch hat are
you a wizard I am a goat turd that it
makes sense at all but I am it lets
skateboard oh my god can I go I want to
go on it oh man that flipped oh wow
this is better than Tony Hawk pro skater
this is less buggy than skate 3 holy
[ __ ] alright go mad I'm such a good
skateboarding I'm the captain oh we're
going of course
I mean I'm driving that's why Oh God yep
I'm sailing away set an open course Oh
God Oh God for the virgin see are there
whales here what the [ __ ] is that
I got him skin where are you taking me
oh now I'm not knocking anything oh god
oh god oh god it's a trap
help I just want to not be a goat right
now thank you
oh there's a goat set you here whoa that
framerate what the [ __ ] well I guess we
[ __ ] swim back what the [ __ ] is going
on with all the whales where did you
guys come for out
oh god it's raining everywhere what the
hell did I do that's why it's so low
framerate stop no stop whales I didn't
ask for this
Oh God all right you know what every I
got a restart I know a lot of people say
they get bored of this game Matt I find
it a lot of fun just to [ __ ] around and
dig explore in this game like thanks all
right so let's go in this boat again all
right let's jump off here I wanna check
out this shark or whatever wow you're
such a good swimmer now please take your
time
oh it's another whale I swam all this
way for another whale No oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god no
all right so I saw a party down here
what the hell is he doing
go ahead and pull job yeah what are you
doing here it's my party good what the
[ __ ]
I can wall run Jesus that's badass oh oh
that's what the signs are right this is
mirrors goad after all no no my god
that's awesome
oh god damn it it's raining Wales again
I don't know what triggers that why
Wales why god I wish there was an easier
way to get [ __ ] inside it there we go
I'm all strapped up let's do this I
thought I was no come on well out nyan
cat what the hell I control it like the
oh it's mine crane yank raft
what the hell okay this picture get out
of the way this would be a lot easier
while I suck at nyan cat go to what the
[ __ ] and what am I supposed to do there
Oh God come on just let me go I just
want to go out thank you thank you very
oh nice I fell underneath the water
fantastic here we go no no no no no no
class ego power uh-uh yes where do we go
now Oh God there now and I missed it oh
[ __ ]
ah lucky I made out of without him I'm
gonna have to end the episode here go
ahead and leave a like right now if you
enjoy watching I really appreciate it
it's gotta come over today I see Bros
tomorrow sails am I